before we go a lost point monkey is back
home after going on an adventure at
buckingham palace with the Queen of
England we mean it five year old
Savannah Hart who lives in Australia
goes everywhere with her toy monkey
Harriet and that included a trip to
London but Harriet got lost somewhere in
the palace
when Savannah's classmates learned
Harriet was missing they wrote a letter
to the Queen as one does to their
surprise buckingham palace box back
containing Harriet and a new friend the
toy Corgi named Rex the palette a palace
staff reportedly said even the Queen had
seen the monkey and they also shared
photos of Harriet's royal vacation when
she got to taste-test a scone way to go
bad yeah magic waiting you know would
have been funny if the Queen had taken a
picture a selfie the parent yeah yeah
that's pretty good that she's Corey he
could go for gay rights that'll do it
for us we'll see you tomorrow right here
on CBS this morning tonight CBS Evening
News with Norah bye-bye